So let's get back to the problem we had with our web server. And that's that we
don't want to crawl the web every time we start the web application. We want to
crawl the web once, store it in a file, read that file, and then be able to
start the server without needing to do any crawls. So what we would like to do
is move the actual crawling out of the server, replace this with something that
just loads a file and turns that file into a web corpus object. So that means we
need something that creates that file, and we're going to put that in the
crawler module. So here's how we're going to modify our code. This is the
crawler.py module, and we're going to add to it. So when we run it from the
command line,when we run it as the main, and this one way to test for that if
the name this is built in defined by Python is equal to name that means we ran
this code directly. But what want to do is do the crawl and write the corpus to
file. That'll be a file that we can load in the server to create the Web Corpus
object. We could do this ourselves. We could add a method to Web Corpus that
would output the object in a way that could be stored in a file, just using the
file write operations that we've seen. And we could have another method that
would read it. This would be quite a bit of work. We'd have to walk the entire
structure to store it. There's actually an easier way to do that, that's built
into Python. And the way to do it is called pickling. This is one of my favorite
modules built into python. What the pickle module allows us to do, is take any
object, actually almost any object. We won't get into the ones that it doesn't
work on. Pickle it, and we can do that by using pickle.dump. That takes in an
object in the file. This'll store the object in a file. We can store that on
disk, we could mail that around, we could do anything we want with it. Then when
we want to get the object back, we can do pickle.load, passing in the file, and
magically we'll get back essentially the same object that we started with. If
this file was created by someone you don't trust, well, they could create a file
so that when you unpickle it, you get an object back that does things you don't
like. It could potentially run any arbitrary code, so only use this with files
you trust. In this case, we're going to create the file ourselves, and hope that
no one else modifies it, and use it in our search engine. So we're going to do
this in two quizzes. The first where you'll dump the file and the second where
you did the load.